die Schlachtfelder der
Ostukraine seit fast zwei Jahren unter
Dauerbeschuss der russischen
Truppen mittlerweile sehen die Wälder
und einst fruchtbaren Felder aus wie
Mondlandschaften von Kratern durchzogen
und verseucht mit
Schwermetallen auch der Naturpark
desnianski im
oblastsumi mit seinen seltenen Tier und
Pflanzenarten wurde von den russischen
Invasoren vermient und angezündet eine
Falle die ukrainische Feuerwehr vor der
sie Drohnen der Armee jedoch rechtzeitig
warnten doch 10% des Waldes verbrannten
die Gebäude der Naturschützer wurden
zerbombt die roten Punkte auf der Karte
bedeuten dass hier Explosionen oder
andere Gewalt etwa Gefechte
stattgefunden
haben die blaue Farbe steht für besetzte
Gebiete hier hatten die Russen ihre
Tankstellen und Werkstätten für ihr
militärisches Gerät hier flossen Öl und
Benzin aus hier wurden Ersatzteile für
Kriegsgerät ausgetauscht es handelt sich
also um militärischen
Abfall am Hamburger Institut für
angewandte Wissenschaften werden die vom
russischen Angriffskrieg verursachten
Umweltschäden von internationalen
Wissenschaftlerinnen untersucht in den
bombardierten Gebieten ist die Belastung
mit Schwermetallen rasant gestiegen
nicht nur die Vergiftung des Bodens ist
gefährlich auch die Landschaften werden
zerstört die Bombenkrater etwa verändern
die
Bodenbeschaffenheit Lebensräume für
Tiere und Pflanzen wurden zerstört die
Biodiversität könnte dauerhaft
schrumpfen bis Kriegsbeginn standen die
acht ukrainischen Naturreservate unter
Schirmherrschaft der
UNESCO ih Zukunft s an den Schutz der
einmaligen Flora und Fauna im desans
Reservat etwa ist derzeit nicht zu
denken sagt ihr Direktor Sergi
kubrakov die Russen haben die Gebäude
des Naturschutzgebiets zuletzt mit 500
Kil Bomben und schweren Geschützen
bombardiert sie haben unschuldige
Pilzsammler erschossen und soar
Milchlaster unter Beschuss genommen all
das vermutlich nur zu dem Zweck die
russchen Kräfte zum Verbleib in dieser
Region zu
bewegen die Künstlerin Katja buchatka
will für die zerstörte Natur einen
Erinnerungsort
schaffen die Geschichte und die
Bedeutung eines Ortes können leicht
verloren gehen als ich die Bombenkrater
sah hatte ich Angst davor wie viel wir
vergessen können und was davon wir in
Erinnerung
behalten durch die dauerbombardement
sich Struktur und Bedeutung einer
Landschaft durch die Bilder der Drohnen
können wir erkennen dass unsere feldter
jetzt wie Sieber
Aussehen von den Kratern die nach den
Explosionen geblieben sind gibt es
inzwischen aber tausende das Land ist
vergiftet mit Chemikalien überall liegen
mien
herum auf diesen kann man keine
Landwirtschaft mehr betreiben meine
Arbeit Hand von
dermöglichkeitee Erinnerung zu behalten
aber auch von der Unmöglichkeit all das
zu
vergessen inzwischen ist die Ukraine das
meistvermiente Land der Welt ein
verwundeter Raum der eine lebendigere
Form des Gedenkens erfordert der eines
wachsenden
Gartens dieser Ort scheint die
Erinnerung zu enthalten von Menschen
Ökosystemen der Landschaft der Ernte der
Erde von Karten und Gebieten
Verluste werden Verluste bleiben aber
etwas zu erschaffen kann der Zerstörung
widerstehen vielleicht erschaffen wir
einen Erinnerungsort nicht damit so
etwas nie wieder passiert sondern
Pflanzen in vollem Wissen um die
Möglichkeit der Wiederholung einen
Garten damit wir etwas zu verlieren
haben
die Idee in jedem Bombenkrater einen
Baum zu pflanzen ist eine Art von
Intervention die wie ich finde diesem
beschädigten Raum angemessen ist denn so
handelt es sich zwar nach wie vor um
einen von menschenemachten Ort aber es
ist keine feindliche Umgebung mehr um
diesen Erinnerungsort zu bewahren müssen
wir uns um ihn
kümmern jeder Baum handelt von jeder
Wunde dieser
Erde auf diese Weise werden wir uns an
jede einzelne dieser Wunden
erinnern viele ukrainische
Wissenschaftlerinnen haben durch den
Angriffskrieg ihren Arbeitsplatz
verloren einige von ihnen erforschen nun
in Hamburg seine fatalen Folgen für
Umwelt und Klima auch damit die Ukraine
nach Kriegsende Entschädigung einfordern
kann wir haben die Verpflichtung aus
Industrieland die für Frieden kämpft und
damit uns auch einsetzen
denn was der Ukraine geschieht konnte
bei uns auch passieren und wenn wir uns
nicht einsetzen dann lassen wir zu d
solche
umweltbedrohung so bleibt wie es
ist noch sind viele Umweltfolgen des
Krieges wie etwa die der Sprengung des
kachovka Staudamms nicht einmal in
Ansätzen erforscht einige der
Auswirkungen auf das Gleichgewicht der
Natur scheinen
irreparabel umso wichtiger ist für die
Ukraine und auch für Europa die Folgen
für die Biodiversität und die dortigen
Lebensräume genau zu
erforschen wir kämpfen jetzt um unsere
Zukunft und ich sehe keine Zukunft ohne
die Natur das betrifft nicht nur uns
Ukrainer sondern alle Bewohner in Europa
und auf unserem
Planeten denn die Natur und unsere
Ökosysteme kennen nun mal keine Grenzen